[Music]  darby 11 days  honestly what are we doing here i told  myself the same thing  rehab doesn't work but excuse me darby  phone for you  my mom is in the hospital i have to  leave darby you know the rules  you leave and you're back in jail  [Music]  [Music]  the road's closed i have to get to salt  lake city no one's getting through until  the storm passes i opened up the visitor  center for some folks and wait it out  there  so what's your name darby sandy  yeah i'm ash  ours do you have the wi-fi  no there's no wi-fi i got one bar by the  tree for about 10 seconds  [Music]  hey are you okay  make yourself comfortable  what what we are here till the storm  clears  getting you out of here as soon as i can  the trick is  play the man not the hand  everybody's got tail huh  what's yours  you're gonna have to figure that one out  for yourself  go go  oh it's gonna be a long night  [Music]  turn out the lights  [Applause]  so  [Music]  you